un estallido social en kazajistán los
disturbios comenzaron el 2 de enero en
el oeste del país en contra del drástico
aumento de precios de combustible y
luego se extendieron a la ciudad más
grande a martí donde se intensificó la
situación y los manifestantes llegaron
hasta edificios gubernamentales
después de cinco días el viernes el
presidente casa newmar tokáyev autorizó
a las autoridades de seguridad disparar
a matar a petición del presidente la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva una alianza militar liderada
por rusia y conformada por seis antiguos
estados soviéticos envía 2500 soldados
como fuerzas de paz las fuerzas de paz
multinacionales de rusia belarús y
armenia también se han desplegado en
servicio de kazajistán y los aviones
militares rusos seguirán transportando a
las fuerzas de paz desde los vecinos
kirguistán y tayikistán el sábado las
autoridades aseguraron que la situación
nacional era estable y el mismo día fue
destituido el vice secretario del comité
de seguridad nacional acusado de
traición un comandante militar ruso dijo
que las tropas se quedarán
en estos momentos la operación
antiterrorista continúa en el territorio
de la república de kazajistán continuará
hasta la completa destrucción de los
terroristas y el restablecimiento del
orden constitucional
éstas han sido las manifestaciones más
grandes en la república centroasiática
desde que kazajistán se independizó de
la unión soviética en 1991 el ministerio
de salud de kazajistán informó el
domingo que 164 personas han muerto en
las protestas según informes oficiales
al menos cinco mil 800 personas han sido
detenidas y más de 2.200 acudieron a
recibir tratamiento por lesiones
causadas por las protestas